حكم الديمقراطيين في امريكا سيكون مختلفا
عن ما كان عليه قبل انتخابات التجديد
النصفي بعد ان فرضت صناديق الانتخابات على
اداره بيض تقسم الكونغرس الديمقراطيون
وطيله الفتره السابقه تمكنوا من فرض
نظرتهم لسياسه العامه من خلال تمرير
قوانينهم العديده وعرضه الجمهوريين لم تكن
عائقا اذ تمكنت اداره بيضا من تمرير
العديد من المقترحات بمباركه غالبيه تضم
الحزبين معا رغم تداعيات التحقيقات التي
رافقت اقتحام مبنى الكونجرس
اداره باندا مررت قوانين بميزانيات غير
مسبوقه اهمها قانون يتعلق بالبنيه التحتيه
بقيمه تفوق الف مليار دولار قوانين اخرى
تتعلق بتاهيل صناعه الامريكيه بلغت قيمتها
280 مليار دولار اقرار مساعدات لاوكرانيا
ايضا بلغ 100 مليار دولار اضافه الى
تعديلات في قانون الزواج والصحه والضرائب
اداره استفادت من سك على بياض لكنها لا
تزال تحمل مشاريع كثيره مكلفه
تحقيقها لن يمر الا بمعركه داخل مجلس
النواب الذي سيطر عليه الجمهوريون
تهديدات انصار ترامب سبقت الانتخابات
ارتفع صوت التهديدات في كل مره اعلنت
واشنطن فيها عن دعم جديد لكيف خاصه وان
الاقتصاد الامريكي يعيش تضخما غير مسبوق
الاولويه اذا لكبح النفقات غير المبرره
سوف نستعد نزاهه هذه الهيئه التي يفترض ان
تخدم مصالح الشعب الامريكي بعد ان غطت
نفسها بالعافيه ظل حكم الحزب الواحد
للديمقراطيين
اشاره واضحه للاموال المقدمه لاوكرانيا
التي ينوي بيضا مواصلات دعمها وبينما
تتاكل شعبيته بعد ان تعرض لانتقادات تتعلق
ببنه هانتر وعلاقته المباشره باوكرانيا
لجا لدعوه ومنحه من برا اقناع النواب في
الكونغرس جمهوريون وان جددوا دعمهم لقياس
لكنهم وصفوا هذا الدعم بمسرحيه سيئه
الاخراج ميزانيه دعم اوكرانيات تمثل الجزء
اليسير من مخططات الجمهوريين وبارتفاع
ارقام المليارات يرتفع الجدل الذي انتقل
الى الكونغرس هذه المره